when the first stay-at-home order was
imposed in march
parts of los angeles were like a ghost
town
nine months on the order's back things
look a little different now
the farmers markets open with limited
numbers but in truth the new rules are
nowhere near as restrictive as last time
and even with case numbers breaking
records this week
farmers like greg think those rules go
too far
i don't think it's justified where have
they justified it nowhere
step back in a space shuttle and look
down on the earth and see what's
happening they're destroying the economy
many of the farmers we spoke to agree
but their customers
see it differently i have friends and
family that are
doctors and nurses and i just wish
people would wear a mask it's not that
hard
uh people in countries doing it right
wore the masks and got on the other side
and we haven't done that yet
even if this helps for like a point zero
zero one percent
so be it you know if any little bit if
it helps that much
wear the freaking mask so dramatic are
the numbers here
so close of the hospitals to capacity
that those orders have now been extended
across california but they're worried
about two things
how bad it's about to get here and
whether everybody will
do as they're told where people are
allowed to gather is at protests
this one against the stay-at-home order
and in particular
a new ban on outdoor dining at
restaurants we've all spent thousands
and thousands of dollars to be compliant
and then to be shut down in this way
it's not just about
the owners but we have staff my husband
and i have
30 employees that we had to let go for
the second time in eight months
that tension between the economy and
health will only intensify
and having traveled the world as a virus
hunter this professor says america now
faces a critical moment
before a vaccine arrives history is
going to when they talk about the
pandemic they're going to write about
this moment in history but we lost so
many lives that we didn't need to
um when this virus just spiraled out of
control that's what's happening
but things like this haven't helped 500
people who booked tests at this site
were then told it would be closed for
the day because a film crew
was shooting a movie there it was
quickly reversed
but it caused confusion and was a
reminder that there can't be business as
usual
when the specter of a pandemic remains
so real
greg milam sky news los angeles